and maybe I have a few more things to
say about the latter part of the book
the part
where there's torture where there's room
101 that has
the thing you fear the most
which is different for all of us and for
Winston that's rats
makes you wonder what that thing is for
each of us
I left a mental note for myself to do
more research into uh
into the historical context the
psychology of the Neuroscience the um
the effectiveness of torture
I think there's probably a lot of really
good work I had a brief conversation
with Andrew huberman
on the phone about this topic Andrew
huberman the brilliant Andrew huberman
host of The huberman Lab podcast you
should listen to and then he mentioned
to me there's a bunch of papers in these
topics uh this has been studied sort of
the the carrot and the Stick of the
ability of incentives and disincentives
to uh control the perception and the
mental state of people and animals
um and he mentioned to me a few folks
that I could talk to on a podcast about
this topic and a few books so I'll
definitely look into this more I think
1984 is probably it uses torture as a
philosophical
description
as a caricature of the operation
of um a totalitarian state but at the
same time a lot of those
elements were all done under Stalin in
the Soviet Union so it's not
it's not like it's very different or
very far from reality it's very very
real the question is
about the actual effect it has on the
human mind
which I really have to think because
um torture in this case breaks Winston
in fact I'd like to believe that many
people in the most fundamental ways
can't be broken in this way
I've seen science
again without extensively reading so
please correct me if I'm wrong but I've
seen signs that shows that torture for
the purpose of intelligence gathering is
not effective
it's not effective to get accurate
information because people will tell you
anything really to stop the torture stop
the physical and the mental uh the
emotional suffering
so that but I think this book is about
the use of torture to completely break
your ability to think and to perceive
the world
one of the things
I uh talked to Andrew about is whether
it's possible to control perception
through to these kinds of things and it
seems that there is literature that
shows it's possible to literally change
your perception of the world like uh in
this case in 1984 it's when you're
holding up four fingers can you actually
make the person believe
that you're holding up five fingers not
because of some weird illusion or uh
just because your vision is blurry or
any of that but you literally when you
look I'm holding four fingers and what
you see is five fingers not because your
vision is poor no your visual cortex the
way you're processing that information
something about the processing changes
completely your perception if I tell you
there's a straight line
can through incentive or disincentive
can you start seeing like a a crooked
line or something like that anyway I
think that there's literature that
supports that which is by the way
terrifying
but the thing I'd like to research into
more
is if that can be long lasting
is that I just don't believe it can't be
if you're not
pushed to your death
yes maybe perception maybe your
willingness to think but your ability to
think your actual ability to think
independent thoughts maybe you're
terrified I understand if you're
terrified of any any more
um
any more kind of
thinking that leads to rebellious
thoughts
like the book mentions the idea of face
crime where you can reveal your thoughts
the inner work is your mind by the
subtleties of your expressions in your
face
and
I think also like Winston or Brian says
if you want to keep a secret you must
also hide it from yourself
so I can understand that
I can understand that maybe that is the
basic mechanism that torture leads to
that you just learn
your body your mind learns to hide
uh
the truth from yourself like you're not
you don't even allow yourself to think
it because you know if you think it is
going to lead to face crime and thought
crime and that's that's going to lead to
more torture
that's possible that's possible but I
just can't imagine the
the capacity for love in the human heart
to be extinguished Through Torture
finally extinguished temporarily yes but
finally
irrecoverably which I think is the basic
claim of the book
that they break so because through the
worst of the torture
Winston gives up Julia
the object of his love
he says that
some things like that
the fact that you said torture her not
me anything to make this stop the fact
that you said that the fact that you
thought that is a is is a is a statement
is a thought you can't walk back to
yourself so it's irrecoverable you just
destroyed your
Faith In Love
I don't think so I think it's possible
we have to remember that this is one
particular character this is one
particular story I think there's a lot
of people in which the um the capacity
to love cannot be broken no matter the
torture but that's an interesting
scientific question but it's also a
human question it's just I I think man
search for meaning there's a lot of
books that explore this kind of question
in the worst of conditions that humans
had to suffer through what still
persists what is the source of meaning
um and I just think that the the the
flame of Love persists through through
atrocities Through Torture through
suffering through all of it
but the claim of the book that yes the
totalitarians they can use torture to
break even that
even that uh which leads to the only
love you're allowed to have which is the
love for Big Brother
so I think the
practically speaking
from the party perspective
I think the point of uh O'Brien's
torture Winston
was to
suffocate The Hope in his mind and heart
so there is no hope by completely
destroying the knowledge of what is and
isn't true so being betrayed and this
kind of uh
goldstein's book about the society and I
don't know if that's true not knowing
anything about Julius basically having
no emotional or intellectual ground to
stand on it's very difficult to have a
like a a sense of where you are like to
have hope you have to have a sense of
where you are and where things could be
and that and then you also portray
yourself like to force you to be a
hypocrite on your own deepest feelings
of love I think that basically
puts you in a place where there's no
hope there's no point it's um
it's apathy it's nihilism
and they're a hard-working member of
society that is nihilistic is probably
what the party wants
because that human will not Rebel
but on the point of Hope
I should mention that there's kind of a
long-running theory that since the
appendix
the appendix is about the details of new
speak the language that the party is
creating and forcing
because that appendix was written in the
past tense and it's talking about new
speak in the past tense and it's written
in English sort of non-newspeak
that means the party and you speak and
all of its elements that we see in the
story is in the past
that the world from which the book is
created has escaped that
and that's a message of hope that
whatever whatever the Rebellion against
the party whether it's passionate
lust and sex whether it's love whether
it's
um
the seeking truth
in a world
full of lies
whatever it is
there's a way out again to me the way
out is love
but that's a hopeful message in this
dystopian novel that even these
perfectly executed totalitarian States
will fall I took a few random notes here
that maybe I'll comment on
I wrote a quote the masses cannot Rebel
until they become conscious
uh there might be either a Winston
observation or an O'Brien statement I'm
not sure but yes so you have to think 80
plus our pros of the working class they
have the power if they want it but they
don't want it they don't want to take it
that's the whole point of the
totalitarian state is to break your will
for Freedom you desire for Freedom uh
break your ability to know that you are
not free
and that's where all of it the changing
of History the double thing the thought
crime all of that uh comes into play
that the torture in the ministry of love
all of that is um
is about preventing the populace from
becoming conscious and again as as per
the cells discussion earlier I wrote
down the O'Brien quote the death of the
individual is not death the party is
immortal
and this is just a interesting
observation about the operation of a
totalitarian state
that it's the idea
and a kind of
amorphous symbol
of the Messianic figure in big brother
is all you need for the party to persist
that person doesn't actually have to
exist and you want an individual doesn't
have to exist it's just the uh division
of society into high middle and low
and the oppression of the Low by the
high
by the centralized inner party that's
all you need and
the individual does not matter in that
and again the way to fight that is to
fight for the individual freedoms
interesting side note is just the quote
I wrote down
from Julia I think
if you keep the small rules you can
break the big ones
and so she in the book is somebody that
follows did the T all the all the rules
of the party she attends all the
committee meetings and all that kind of
stuff and just as like the model citizen
from the perspective of the party and so
that allows it to break the big rules
like have passionate sex with people
like the the really or fall in love all
the all the Forbidden things and I think
that's actually a good way to exist in
the world I think for a lot of us
there's probably a bunch of things that
bother us
in the in the local world around us in
the bigger world and I think you have to
pick your battles you have to
not get lost in the muck
of small battles if you want to
um have at least one or a few big
victories in your life that make for a
better world
I think at least in my
sense it's easy to get distracted by the
little things that bother you in life
and I think staying focused on the big
things again picking your battles and
staying with that for as long as
possible working your ass off to solve
one problem for as long as possible not
giving up in against impossible odds
against all the criticism all of that
that's the way to solve those big
problems and of course that's not what
Julia is talking about but in a sense
she is also because in that particular
case the totalitarian state is the
problem and the way to Rebel is to plant
that seed
of uh
rebellion in each of the people she has
sex with
that uh that we are human that we have
lust for each other that we have the
ability to love each other and that is
the necessary Act of rebellion there
that that is the big leap for her at
least uh in that kind of society
I should also mention that
there's a lot of interpretations of the
different the small and the big things
in this book so it's very possible in
the case of Julia that Winston was
played he was set up with Julia
he was set up to feel all those things
he was set up to have that little Secret
Cove where he can write on his desk in
the diary and dream of rebelling against
the the uh the state dream of the
Brotherhood
it's unclear to me why
an oppressive state would want people to
have that little
journey of Desiring freedom in all its
manifestations I'm not sure but maybe
O'Brien's statement that the
the purpose of torture is torture hold
some wisdom
that
to attain absolute power
you also have to have
a willingness
and a mechanism to attain absolute
suffering in the populace
and maybe this is a way to maximize
suffering
is to give them hope before you crush it
again
the way out
to me
and the takeaway from this book
the way out is love